[Music]
a bombshell from the world's best chess
player magnus carlson announcing he will
not defend his title next year
it's very simple that i am not motivated
to play
another another match i don't have
a lot to gain i don't particularly like
it it's opened a lot of doors i feel
like it's um
it's my time to to go from the world
championship
the 31 year old norwegian who has spent
more than a decade at the top of the
world rankings was introduced to the
game by his father when he was 5 years
old
carlson has indicated an interest in
changing the championship's classical
match format
but despite an open dialogue with the
governing body fidei he chose to give up
his title the last grand master to do so
was bobby fischer in 1975.
chess enjoyed a comeback during the
coronavirus pandemic thanks in part to
the netflix production the queen's
gambit
around half a billion people play the
game worldwide
and the popular series prompted about
100 million people to open accounts to
play online
you know the reality is that as chess
has exploded uh for fans online and um
on every medium chess is consumed more
than it ever has been before
just played perfectly in the longest
time controls may not actually be what
the fans want to see there's been
massive movements toward um formats and
events online time controls that uh
deliver the excitement the fans want
which is actually more mistakes more
opportunities for the best players to
capitalize on those mistakes therefore
you know brilliant brilliant moments
that everyone wants to see and it's just
a more consumable product
carlson has set his sights on perfecting
his skills and has no plans to retire
anytime soon frankly i'm excited to get
back to
where i was i was all set on
trying to improve
trying to be better do the right things
play the tournaments be the best in the
world
and not care about the world
championships
the beauty of the game going beyond a
world championship checkmate
jillian wolfe al jazeera